all right up next the woman who may
change the way you think about work-life
balance her strategy
Al Roker shocks his today co-anchors
with a surprise visit oh my God what's
up brother
right back Al made his first in-person
appearance on the show since being
hospitalized for knee replacement
surgery earlier this month and is today
family couldn't contain their excitement
we've seen anchor teams and you've seen
them come and go who's there ow when I
when I sit in my chair and I look to my
left and Al is there I know the world's
okay and I feel like alad's more than
the weather it's about it's about a
sense of calm stability and hey honey
it'll all be okay I think we're kind of
there for each other and because
especially these hours and the Today
Show they always say like morning
television is a special ecosystem so we
all kind of get each other we get our
lives and so you need to be able to have
family Al's appearance comes after he
gave a virtual health update on the show
Tuesday and revealed he'd return next
week he said I'm gonna be honest this
this you know I've had a number of
replacement body Replacements yeah yeah
it's not a big surprise uh this one has
been the toughest one yet that's your
new name
last November Al was hospitalized twice
for blood clot complications and since
the 68 year old's been working hard on
his recovery this is my first time
walking in the park really since since
uh I was in the hospital back in
November out here in the park getting
some steps in taking the time wow like
you used to walk through Central Park
and he was walking along and he'd rack
up like 10 or 20 000 steps well my
doctor told me he wanted me walking five
miles a day call them at the end of the
week I called him he said where are you
I said I'm 35 miles from home
with all Al's been through his health
struggles helped him put a lot into
perspective
[Music]
one of the things I learned over the
last several months uh is the the power
of positive thinking and the power of
prayer I know made made a tremendous
difference and once you have a bit of a
health scare you really realize you
can't take it for granted
[Music]